welcome back to las vegas now with more
families traveling and getting together
this holiday season many of us will be
giving more gifts right lifestyle expert
amy sewell is here from bed bath and
beyond the sponsors of this next segment
with ideas to help you gift happier
i'm amy sewell most of us are excited
about gathering with family for the
holidays and experiencing the joy of
spending time together and giving gifts
in person this year from the affordable
to the luxurious bed bath beyond has
home and kitchen essentials that your
loved ones can enjoy any time of year
[Music]
first the foodies on your list will love
the versatile ninja digital airfry oven
this is an airfryer convection oven and
toaster oven all in one it's especially
great for small spaces since you can
actually flip it up and store it against
the backsplash when you're not using it
you can save space and money with the
new sodastream fizzy one touch sparkling
water maker instead of buying sparkling
water you can turn tap water into
sparkling in just a few seconds for
coffee lovers this nespresso virtuo
coffee and espresso machine is an ideal
gift it makes four different sizes of
espresso or coffee so everyone can enjoy
being their own barista
for warm and comfortable gifts with a
modern vibe bed bath beyond exclusive
studio 3b collection has something for
everyone this chunky knit throw blanket
feels like curling up in your favorite
sweater that also makes it perfect for
settling in with a cup of hot cocoa to
bend your favorite holiday movies these
glass jar or middle bowl candles and
woodsy fragrances like green fur and
cedar make fabulous hostess gifts and
stocking stuffers
after a long day of holiday activities
or playing sports people can relax with
this sharper image power boost deep
tissue massager they will also love the
sharper image calming cozy electric
blanket now this is not your standard
electric blanket as you can see it's
actually a cocoon-like wrap that has
three therapeutic heat settings and
three massage settings to relieve muscle
aches and loosen stiff joints you can
also give the gift of sleep with this
casper weighted blanket if you've never
tried one of these it makes you feel
like you're being wrapped in a big hug
another way to stay warm and cozy is to
wrap up with a warm towel after a shower
or bath
this towel warmer is from bed bath and
beyond's new spa inspired haven
collection this affordable line also has
super soft towels and robes made from
100 organic cotton and other modern
essentials to help you transform your
bath into an oasis
finally you can get the gift of a clean
house with the shark cordless vertex pro
vacuum this combines the power and
performance of a full-size vacuum with
the ease of a cordless stick
if you have someone on your list with
pets they will love this vacuum because
it has a self-cleaning brush roll that
easily picks up pet hair
whether you're decorating entertaining
or searching for the perfect gift bed
bath and beyond to make shopping
effortless and convenient
their improved mobile app offers quick
price checks organizes your coupons and
offers and quickly locates items in the
store
in select stores you can even skip the
checkout line with the app's new scan
and buy feature if you have some things
to pick up at the last minute you can
shop online and get free curbside and
in-store pickup within the hour along
with options like conventional shipping
or even same day delivery you can get
everything you need for the holidays
whenever you need it
for more information go to bedbath and
beyond.com happy holidays
thank you to bedfast and beyond for
sponsoring this segment i love bath and
beyond for more information visit the
website on your screen in las vegas now
we'll be right back